this week would have been the 80th
birthday
of iconic martial arts film star bruce
lee
he died unexpectedly at age 32 but his
legacy
and his work endure and much in part to
the remarkable efforts
of his daughter shannon lee and in her
new book
be water my friend the teachings of
bruce lee
is available now i've been reading it
it's incredible
shannon thank you so much for joining us
thank you thank you you know there was a
sentence that really spoke to me how
does one honor the plain fact of their
dna
while at the same time understanding
that it doesn't mean anything
about one's own soul or does it throw in
my decision to spend a good portion of
my life protecting and promoting
the legacy of one of the humans who
gifted
me with this life and who has meant so
much to me
i i really appreciated reading that as
someone
who is um very loyal
very inspired uh by my own family
and really want to carry on their legacy
and
you've done such an amazing job um
carrying the torch for someone who is so
beloved idolized uh he is such an
important figure
to so many of us well thank you and and
by the way thank you for
expressing that and pulling that section
out of the book
so thank you glad i just love your dad
so much shannon i watched all of his
movies i was obsessed
and when i got to go uh to
make charlie's angels i showed them a
clip reel i made like a visual tape
of scene-to-scene footage and one of my
big
things was bruce lee and what's it like
to have the coolest
most appealing capable
dad
[Laughter]
i mean on the one hand it's
amazing right you're like yeah that's my
that's my dad
you know but on the other hand too like
growing
up sometimes it can feel a little
like pressure but it's pretty awesome i
mean when i was a kid i used to say
to people like you know when people
would say oh my dad can beat up your dad
and be like
no but really my dad can my dad could be
for sure 100
you're like my dad can beat up your dad
all of his friends in this entire town
in one adult swoop exactly
exactly no but but i think what you
speak to is really amazing like his
energy his dynamism his
power his essence like and
and and how comfortable he was in his
skin and the way he just sort of like
occupied space fully is
phenomenal it was really interesting to
me
to understand when uh please tell me if
i'm getting this right
his master was explaining
the water metaphor i mean the way he
said it is water can flow
or it can crash right like water is
the softest most gentle life-giving
pliable beautiful thing
but it's also can be a tsunami and
i mean this is like a lifelong practice
right like how to find balance and what
your particular balance is and what's
called for in a particular situation
there's
never just like one solution never just
one
right answer yeah you know you have to
be present to it
and i think that's a lot like parenting
like i have a toolbox for my kids and i
try to
practice a few different things so
they're familiar and consistent but that
tool that worked yesterday
might not work today so i better have a
backup plan
and it's funny too because my mom was
one of those moms who was like i'm just
gonna try a bunch of stuff with my kids
you know i had the tap jazz
piano ballet and i can't even tell you
how
like crappy i felt in a ballet class i
didn't have the body
i wasn't that type and i finally found
karate
and all of a sudden i was like these are
my people
you want me to punch something i have so
much anger
that i'm supposed to not let out but i
have it in me
but it was the first time in my life i
remember finding a place
that i really felt like physically
emotionally
and like character-wise i just felt
finally at peace totally it gives you
this sense of you know internal strength
i think which is like the most
amazing part of it more than the
external strength it's the internal
strength that i
that i love so much um i
uh before we go i also found a detail
that i really loved which is that
the san francisco giants hold an annual
bruce lee um night
uh yep that is so cool and
i as soon as it's safe i feel like i
need to go to this
because i feel like i will be looking
around and going
i found my people again
well you're definitely invited we go
every year except of course for this
past year and um
you know especially this year it's as
you said it's going to be his 80th
birthday
he was born in san francisco so it's his
hometown
so anytime you want to come let's do it
well perhaps next year
we can light the torch for your
incredible
father who made the most important mark
for so many of us
in this world i'm so amazed at how
beautifully europe holding his legacy
while speaking so many interesting
internal truths about yourself
oh my gosh everything that you said like
you feel this
pull this sort of like spiritual
alliance
to your heritage that is
is and isn't you know um
at the same time it just resonates
so much with me and so i'm really
grateful to be able to have a
conversation with you and thank you
thank you so much shannon lee season two
of warrior
airs fridays at 10 p.m eastern and
pacific standard time on cinemax and
seasons one and two are streaming
on hbo max so you can check it all out
cute boys doing fun stuff
thank you shannon so much thank you